día de resistencia en Israel y el Primer
Ministro Benjamín netanyahu
desplazándose por aire para llegar al
aeropuerto para poder viajar a Italia
una victoria para los manifestantes que
cortaban la vía y que terminaron siendo
sacados por la policía
las marchas se sucedieron por todo
Israel masiva reivindicativas y contra
El Ejecutivo de ultraderecha
mujer
estoy protestando contra El golpe del
régimen que está poniendo en riesgo el
país que todos amamos no tenemos otra
opción sino expresamos nuestra opinión
hoy levantamos la cabeza y hablamos
mañana no tendremos la oportunidad de
hacerlo
estas protestas son plurales e incluso
históricas destaca la participación de
militares Una institución demarcada
línea política desde el gobierno
condenaron las manifestaciones
está permitido manifestarse lo demostré
durante décadas protestar gritar eso es
democracia no se debe permitir la
anarquía
las protestas se repiten desde enero
netanyahu Busca una reforma judicial que
le dé influencia al gobierno a la hora
de elegir jueces también limitaría la
capacidad de la Corte Suprema para
legislar o fallar en contra del
ejecutivo